never done to put up in my life just
start with these ones maybe like the
ones to decide I support Bible just mace
amount here and I'm giving you a tour
answer in George's Park come with me
we're currently in the indoor pitch the
free G pitch so obviously it's a massive
honor to put the English L on in the
past maybe putting that shirt on the
house felt heavy but I think definitely
now when you put that shirt on you get
the sense of being the fearless see that
to follow me into the gym my natural
habitat what Dex doing at the moment
just is on these just keep working hard
I keep telling to get up here done put
up in my life technique just start with
these ones just like little steps why
not maybe like the ones to the side
maybe trying to get that little bit of
shrimp that little bit of bone going on
[Laughter]
you just know when this guy's coming cuz
you're so loud coming here boys so I'm
just having a little tour around the
place yeah a little toys what just
around the place that's really brilliant
oh good that was good done with it that
was good and I could have crumbled there
but I kind of kept it together so it can
be quite daunting walking into a change
room of all the big names but for me
personally I'll see they welcome in I
felt so welcome around all the boys
there's obviously leaders there's
massive leaders in the group that
hurricane
and they also welcome you in as a young
player coming in oh we got one more stop
I love it
so at the moment we're in the area where
we put our boots on getting ready start
to train in waiting for Tammy and fig to
come out always late in the dressing
room blast but these are my boots here
so I got em em on the side and then yeah
we make our way down here to put our GPS
on how far we run in in training you get
mine not running very far and tell you
that and then make our way out here onto
the pitch so this pictures obviously
means quite a lot to me
played in many at times and this was the
first time I trained with the first team
on this pitch obviously a very proud
moment to be called up and to be playing
so yeah I got my first call-up last year
well not while I was at Derby yeah Frank
Lampard all she was my manager and he
called me into the his meeting room and
then he just obviously said to the news
about that I've been called up I think a
massive part was obviously working with
Frank Lampard last season and then move
into this season as well as an attacking
midfielder and as a midfielder that
wants to do the the defensive side as
well I don't think there's any one
better to kind of learn off so obviously
a lot of people know how close me and
Declan where I saw and to be with him is
also he mastered for me and we've always
spoke about the opportunity of maybe
playing together once more so now is the
time and obviously we played come on and
he was playing the game and I come on
the last international break sources
brilliant moment for us as best mates to
play for England together thanks guys
thanks for having me just about to go to
the gym now throw some weights about do
some bench rest of the sea layer thank
you
you